hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Thomas aquinas's Summit
first part question two deals with
Arguments for God's existence and Thomas
sets out his famous five ways all of
which involve observation on our part
and then causal reasoning back to
something that is going to be the cause
of the things that we observe something
that is going to be superlative the
greatest and we're going to see this
very much so in the fourth way which as
Thomas tells us is based upon gradations
or degrees sometimes it's translated
in Latin observed in things and The
observed there things that what we come
across what we discover right in
venientur
um in Rebus in the things of our
experience and in the world
so he's already talked about you know
necessity and possibility and efficient
causality and movement or change at this
point now he's actually going to go in a
different metaphysical Direction and
talk about the more and the less or the
greater and the lesser the Magus and the
menus and he tells us that we see this
in things so for example some things are
found to be more good right Magis at
Minas bonum or more or less true greater
or lesser degrees of truth
or more noble and less noble Nobile in
this case Nobile
and we see this with any sort of
comparative word that we can use now we
should pause for a second because the
example that he's going to use to argue
for this
isn't quite the same as these very
general terms like true good Noble even
the most generic term being that he's
going to bring up he's going to use
heat as an example and this actually
does make sense within the framework of
Aristotelian physics and metaphysics and
this notion by the way of degrees of
being
you might automatically associate it
with platonic philosophy you might say
what's it doing here in Thomas Aquinas
he's an Aristotelian after all well it
also plays a role in Aristotelian
philosophy as well and it was a common
assumption back in ancient philosophy
the stoics also talk about degrees of
being and so this is kind of a us you
know a commonplace Viewpoint that a lot
of us in the modern era don't
necessarily share and if you don't buy
into that well the proof isn't really
going to go anywhere so let's look at
what Aquinas actually tells us he says
comparative terms Magus at Minos
are said
in uh relation in different ways uh
varying degrees
by which they approach to approximate
appropriate literally being in the
neighborhood of
um what it is
that is the greatest
in that thing so you know we can talk
about the truest right there's a
superlative
we can talk about the best optimum we
can talk about the most noble the three
things that he's brought up so far
Thomas is going to talk about heat
and he's going to bring this in even
though heat is more of a quality a
physical quality right than these these
other things which seem to be a bit more
value-laden or or metaphysical
and he's going to do this in order to
try to provide us with an analogy so he
says
just as uh something that is more hot or
warm maggi's kalidum is that insofar as
it is approaching to what is
hottest what has the greatest amount of
heat Moxie May kalido
so Thomas is saying there is some sort
of you know most in this case some
superlative some Supreme and he's
actually going to hear as opposed to
most of the other proofs he's going to
bring in some Aristotle from the
metaphysics uh where Aristotle tells us
when many things possess some property
in common many things belonging to a
single genre we could say
um then the one that most fully
possesses that is in fact the cause of
the other things in that that genre and
then he uses the example just as fire
which is the hottest right or in which
is the highest degree of heat is the
cause of all the other hot things now do
we actually buy this with our
present-day physics no we've got a whole
different understanding we don't need to
go into that but you see what he's
driving at and Thomas could be wrong
about
heat and Fire
but he could still be right about the
things that he's most interested in or
rather let's say the qualities
and in a certain way the substance
that he's most interested in so just as
we can say there's a more and less with
heat and there's a cause of the others
which is the thing that has the most we
can talk about the truest right there
are different degrees of truth or
trueness or possession of Truth or
embodying truth and there is something
that is the
top of that set of degrees or gradations
the truest and that is the cause of the
truth and all the other things
likewise goodness there are good and bad
better and worse right and we get to the
top the best the optimum and that is the
cause of the goodness of all the other
things and nobility here which we might
see as corresponding to the honestum as
well as the nobility the nobody
um something that has intrinsic you know
value within itself it's kind of close
to being good and true isn't it and so
the nobilisimon uh is the cause of
everything else having nobility in this
sense
so
um he's going to tell us that there is
something there for
um which has these things what is the
truest and best and most noble of beings
is most in being is one way we can
translate it Moxie May ends so ends is
coming from essay the word that's the
infinitive to be ends is something that
exists something that is being or has
being right and so the thing that is
Maxime ends is the thing that is the
greatest degree of being at the very top
of the entire ladder you can't get any
higher than that and that is going to be
the cause as Thomas is going to say
not just of true truth or goodness or
nobility or whatever else we want to
bring up but of being itself
for the other things uh essan right in
this uh he says there is something
um that is the cause
of being and goodness
now notice what he says after that and
any other Perfection and here he
actually is using the word Perfection
some translators smuggle the word
Perfection into the earlier ways but
it's not really there it is here in this
part of article 3 where he says
um
right there is something that is the
cause uh of being and goodness
of whatever other Perfection you want to
bring up so Perfections is heat a
Perfection no not really goodness is a
Perfection truth is a Perfection
nobility is a Perfection we might add in
some other things as well these are
essentially uh if we want to get away
from Thomas and look at earlier authors
these are essentially what we typically
call the Divine attributes right
whatever if we want to use ansem
whatever it is better to be than not to
be God is that and God would be at the
highest rank of that this actually is
quite similar to the reasoning that is
going on in Anselm's monologian if you
pay attention to the early arguments in
that book so Thomas is producing here a
very interesting argument which is not
really about fire but is really more
about these uh very generic
attributes and saying that there is
something that is the highest in each of
these and these are unified into the you
know thing that has the greatest being
which is the cause of being goodness and
every other perfection
in the things that we observe within the
world including ourselves we should say
in Omnibus
and he says and this
is what we call God now notice an
interesting change of language here in
the third proof as I had pointed out
earlier there isn't any invocation of
this is God by the way it's just kind of
left for us to figure out in the first
two arguments or ways or proofs Thomas
said this is what everybody calls God or
this is what everybody understands by
God
here he's not making such a sweeping
assertion right this is what we
call God
why does he
change the language like that is it just
for variety's sake or is he does he
perhaps have in the back of his mind ah
maybe not everybody will buy into this
gradations or degrees of various things
like goodness or truth the way that I
myself and we as an intellectual
Community who are relying upon Aristotle
in this case but have also have read and
some and other thinkers uh maybe not
everybody will buy this but we certainly
call this highest greatest you know to
the superlative degree of being and
therefore of Truth goodness nobility we
call this God that we leave that an open
question for you to ponder